y bueno estar de santiago mucho gusto
mire lo que se trata es tener un tratado
internacional que permita que los países
puedan atender de manera unificada un
problema como la pandemia que estamos
viviendo que el acce de medicamentos
tratamientos equipos y vacunas sea lo
más equitativo y lo más
probable que todos los países tengan
acceso a lo mismo sin embargo tenemos
ciertas dificultades por la palabra
tratado un tratado por lo general tiene
que pasar a través de los congresos
tiene que ser ratificado y es ahí donde
pudiera haber alguna cuestión vinculante
mientras se atrae a través de los
mecanismos normales de la visión mundial
de la salud que son propuestos en la
asamblea mundial de la salud cada mayo
pues no necesariamente son vinculantes
en cuanto a que no hay sanciones para
que se justifique o para qué
si lo que se tiene que hacer son así
como deseables que los países firman y
tenemos el caso claro del reglamento
sanitario internacional que pocos países
siguen cuando hay algún problema en la
unión becerra esta emergencia sanitaria
a nivel mundial que falencias dejó en
evidencia por parte de los organismos
internacionales también de los estados y
de la cooperación mundial más allá de la
capacidad económica
primero que la relación mundial de la
salud no tiene ningún proceso de poner
sanciones o de obligar a los países a
que hagan lo que tienen que hacer dentro
del marco del reglamento sanitario
internacional segundo los países tienen
una visión de seguridad nacional y
nacionalista antes que atender los
programas globales y pues desde una
perspectiva de país eso es normal y lo
otro es las grandes dificultades que hay
en cuanto a que la falta de inversión de
los países en sal en salud hemos visto
los problemas que esto ha causado
-soy problemas e incluso en países ricos
que no han podido hacer un frente
adecuado a la pandemia señor becerra que
lectura si usted de la posición que
tiene rusia china eeuu y también brasil
de no ser parte de este tratado de esta
propuesta internacional
primero porque los niños tienen su
propia iniciativa de global health
security que es promovida por el cdc a
nivel global para tratar precisamente de
compensar todas las falencias que tiene
el reglamento sanitario internacional yo
creo que esta parte ellos piensan que
pues está pudiera ser la mejor manera de
fortalecer a los estados para poder
atender este tipo de problemas segundo
de que esta es la visión nacionalista de
qué
y mientras yo pueda contener estos
problemas en el interior de mi país
entonces ya podría ver los problemas
señor francisco becerra ex subdirector
de la organización panamericana de la
salud y consultor en salud pública
muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros aquí en france 24